uh let's see where are we going next oh
remember if you want to get on your name
needs to be name and location or
location and name however you want to do
it in whatever order you want to do it
like for example Connor from New Jersey
is our next caller today Connor what's
going on
hi David hello oh you already told us
not to ask how you're doing um I I have
a question but I wanted to pass on words
of affirmation for starters please I've
been following you for a little while
now like I honestly solidly since the
Trump arrest was announced and all that
you remember me calling in the day prior
I was like I don't think he's gonna get
arrested but you don't have to remember
okay my whole point is I've been
following you and honestly I I grew up
in like a more Republican conservative
house and I might have those views
honestly I don't even know where I fall
politically but
listening to you I just feel like you
are so well thought out so your
methodology of breaking down issues is
just so solid and I wish that there was
more people that claim to be
conservative or republican that could be
so again well thought out I mean like
you're inspiring to me like I hope that
I could help change the perspective on
conservatism well I appreciate that very
much you know you know move the
Republican Party forward and help open
discussion and not have it be this
close-sided debate between the two
parties I mean I really think it's
possible I young people have to say
enough is enough I mean I'm not against
trans people I support gay rights but I
still call myself conservative I really
don't even know what that means at this
point yeah but all I know is I want
change I want people to stop picking
sides and actually have these sides
working together for a bipartisan
Solutions what issues are you
conservative on
I don't really know honestly I think
it's more so of just like how I carry
myself really so I don't know I I to be
fairly honest with you I've just grown
up in an atmosphere that was like that
it sounds like you're sort of culturally
conservative because if you're a really
conservative but politically I might
lean more Democrat or left whatever you
want to call it and um honestly I really
wish that people didn't see how I
carried myself and thought that was how
I carried my political views
interesting at the end of the day I find
you really inspiring and I want to know
how can you uh what can you suggest to
people like me who follow you and want
to help you know bring more discussion
in the world or at least in the United
States when it comes to really stupid
issues that have been around since the
60s well I think it's just engage and
talk to people and share your story and
say Hey you know I kind of defaulted to
a particular world view just by virtue
of where I was born but the more I
examine a lot of these issues I come to
to realize maybe I was wrong about some
of these things and I think that there's
it's really powerful to hear from people
on one's quote side as trite as that may
be and say hey yeah I am from the same
place you are I was raised the same way
but I've been able to actually get some
distance and get some facts and I've
revised my view you can do the same
thing and there's no shame in that I
think that can be very powerful
and I guess one thing I want to ask you
before you get some more people David is
do you like personally I don't think I
should switch to becoming a Democrat I
think I should be trying to help bring
the Republican Party forward even if I
don't vote Republican I think the people
that I'm around I should try to help
open their minds to these discussions
and help it not be so hard for people on
the left if I really empathize with both
these positions
I don't know that it really matters
whether you're registered one way or the
other I mean it's it's I don't think
that that's the most important thing one
way or the your story is still the same
story regardless of you know your party
affiliation I think so just keep doing
me and hope to open more discussion I
guess that's what I would say yeah thank
you David honestly it's been awesome to
listen to this the short while all right
Connor from Jersey great to hear from
you very very interesting uh message
that's for sure good habits have to be
sustainable something you'll actually
stick to I start my mornings with a
scoop of ag1 by our sponsor athletic
greens because it's just so simple one
scoop of ag1 gives me the entire day's
worth of 75 high quality vitamins and
minerals from whole food sources half of
Americans are deficient in vitamin A C
and magnesium taking that scoop of ag1
makes sure that I'm getting the
nutrients I want without fumbling with
different capsules and dosages and all
of these things ag-1 is also way more
cost effective than buying all of those
different vitamin vitamins I drink ag1
straight with water because I like the
taste but you could put it in a smoothie
a juice a protein shake I would not
promote bogus supplements making crazy
claims there's no crazy claims here ag1
is just a simple product it does what it
says it does it helps me get what I want
to get every day and when you go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman you will get a
free year supply of vitamin D plus five
free travel packs of ag1 I've talked
about vitamin D before the link is down
below